et sinon vous venez souvent sur cette
plage c'est un peu mon repère secret mon
mari ne le connaît pas
au fait je m'appelle Marie-Line moi
c'est connard
merci de t'être déplacé désolé je suis
en retard à cause de mon boulot n'hésite
pas à me le dire si tu as besoin que je
te rappelle pourquoi il faut qu'on se
voit régulièrement toi et moi c'est une
épreuve les six premiers mois de liberté
vous pouvez m'aider vous cherchez un
truc en particulier je pensais
à vous êtes sérieux de préférence avec
le mari qui meurt à la fin je vois ouais
cela
[Musique]
j'espère qu'on va se revoir moi aussi je
suis incapable de penser à quelqu'un
d'autre depuis notre rencontre
j'aimerais que ce moment de finisse
jamais mon mari s'est mis à m'engueuler
et ça a fini en dispute je suis désolé
peut-être qu'il me quittera il pourrait
mourir
si on le fait alors c'est pour toujours
oui je suis d'accord
cette nuit forcément
évitons nous parler jusqu'à ce qu'on ne
risque plus rien le crime ne paie pas
mais tu sais déjà ça toi bête un truc à
me dire
tu me promets qu'on sera réuni je te le
promets
[Musique]